مشجع ايفرتون يتخلى عن تذكرته الموسميه
قميص ارسنال البطل يباع مجانا وحمله جديده
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
قام احد مشجعين دي ايفرتون الانجليزيه
بالتخلي عن تذكرته الموسميه بطريقه غريبه
المشجع واسمه اندرو جونز كان قد اضاع
محفظته بداخلها التذكره الموسميه لينشر
احد مشجع النادي تغريد على تويتر يبحث من
خلالها عن صاحب هذه المحفظه اندرو اجابه
وقال له احتفظ بها رد حصد العديد من
التعليقات المضحكه بعد مسائم هذا المشجع
من فريقه وقرر عدم حضور مبارياته مجددا
وقبل ثلاث جولات من نهايه البريميرليج هوى
سعر تذكره ارسنال ضد ولفرهامبتون في الجرس
الاخيره من ثلاثه وخمسين الف باوند في
السوق السوداء الى نحو 300 وخمسين باولد
بعدما اصبحت مهمه تتويج بالبطوله صعبه
وكان سعر التذكره مباراه تتويج ارسنال ضد
الوورد قد وصل الى اسعار خياليه بعدما
ارتفع الطلب عليها من طرف مشجع الفريق حول
العالم وليس في انجلترا فقط وكل هذا تبخر
مع سقوط الفريق بثلاثيه نظيفه امام
برايتون
الامر لم يتوقف عند هذا الحد بعدما عرض
احد مشجع ارسنال القميص الفريق للبيع دون
مقابل صاحب القميص كان قد جهزه للاحتفال
باللقب وكتب عليه كلمه شامبيونز ورقم 23
في اشاره لبطل الموسم الحالي
في المانيا لا يزال يثير الجدل بالقرارات
التي يتخذها في حق نجوم الفريق وبحسب شبكه
سكاي المانيا فان المدرب قرر الاستغناء عن
خدمات ساديو ماني وجوكانسيلو ويعتي قررت
باستبعاد الثنائي بعد تهميشه لتوماس
حول رحيل غوريسكا في الصيف الحالي بعد ان
كان واحدا من اعمده الفريق البفري كما جدد
عقده مؤخرا حتى صيفي 2006